people are not fully rational and they
they do they make many choices that if
they reflected upon them they would do
differently there's no question about
that and we have a fair understanding
actually of what is happening at least
at the individual level my sense is that
we have explored a lot of what is
happening I wouldn't say there's going
to be no further progress but we've
explored along the major tendencies well
the major tendencies of people tend to
frame things very narrowly they take a
narrow view of decision makings they
look at the problem at hand and they
deal with it as if it were the only
problem very frequently it's a better
idea to look at problems as they will
recur throughout your life and then you
look at the policy that you're to adopt
for a class of problems difficult to do
would be a better thing people who frame
things narrowly in the sense for example
that they will save and and borrow at
the same time instead of somehow
treating their whole portfolio of assets
as as one thing if people were able to
take a broader view they would in
general make better decisions so that is
certainly one one of the weaknesses of
human decision-making we call it narrow
framing mental accounting you know is is
a big deal this is the way that we live
so we have we have we keep our money in
different mental accounts for which we
have different rules so people will will
well of course they spend their spending
money but then there is a hierarchy of
the accounts that they will touch they
will spend money that they have stored
for vacation quite often
before they will spend whatever they are
thinking of a savings for their
children's education so those are mental
accounts for which people have different
rules more foolishly this is pretty
sensible because
accounting is a tool of self-control but
more foolishly investors tend to view
each stock that they buy as a mental
account and they want to sell it when it
is a winner and so they tend to sell
their winners and and just hang on to
their losers in their portfolio and that
turns out to make them substantially
poorer than if they had done things
differently you need to be numerous for
certain kinds of decisions so number
eight people have a significant
advantage over those who are not
understanding compounding compound
interest makes a huge difference whether
you're a credit card borrower or
somebody with saving people have a very
hazy idea of compound interest
and it's very detrimental so I would say
that first of all you need to be
numerate
that many people are then then you need
to frame things broadly I mean that's it
frequently goes with numeracy but it's
not quite the same thing and then by
taking the broad view it is very
important not to have overly strong
emotional reactions to events and what I
mean by that is that most of us tend to
respond to gains and to losses to
changes that happen in our life actually
you're better off if you frame things
broadly and you think of you win a few
you lose a few and you have very limited
emotional response to small gains and do
small losses that tends to induce better
decision-making
you